after a long two-year wait eldon ring
has finally received its second trailer
that showcased the first look at its
gameplay
so what exactly did we just see in this
new trailer well let's take a deeper
look
the trailer begins with a medieval style
landscape that pulls straight out of
from software's unique style
however elder ring's setting features a
massive tree in the backdrop
that looks to be the urgery likely
inspired by yggdrasil of norse mythology
we see a knight who by whistling calls
forth a steed who's able to appear out
of thin
air while we learned that there would be
horseback riding in elder ring after his
2019 reveal
this is the first time we've been able
to see it in action and it looks
absolutely fantastic with the desolate
backdrops in the distance
we've yet to see horseback riding in a
from software game so it'll be
interesting to see how this impacts both
combat and movement
which we saw a brief segment of in the
trailer as this is a from software game
evocative visuals are part of this
identity and we see just that in the
next scenes
a walking stone creature with a bell
hanging beneath it and chain beings
attached to
and dragging a carriage are just some of
the imagery we get right off of the bat
it's hard to say what the creature with
the belt will be for but i honestly
don't think this will be an enemy we see
the protagonist riding toward it and
it's likely this is something helpful to
the character
perhaps this is a bell you have to ring
to grant access to new
area or kingdom after this we see a
return of torches and lighting effects
after the fiasco of dark souls 2 with
the trailers and initial demos showing
torches and lighting being a major
factor of the game
only for them to be removed in the final
game with the current gen
engine i think it's safe to say that
torches will work as intended here
i can't stress enough how much i love
the visuals i've seen so far in the game
with the protagonist climbing up a
ladder showing a giant face on the
ground below
a pot with arms attached reminds me of
the mimic chest from the souls games
perhaps there'll be creatures like this
that blend in with the environment
making them harder to detect
and something that can better ambush
players by blending into the background
as the trailer goes on we get a glimpse
at a centipede-like enemy which
interestingly is wearing a crown
hidetaka miyazaki and the developers
that from
software don't make their creatures just
to look cool and intimidating
there's always a story behind them so i
definitely want to find out why
exactly this creature is wearing a crown
and if perhaps it's a race in the game
that has either been
formed to look like this or if they're
part of a larger civilization
the combat showcase here looks similar
to the souls games
as the protagonist approaches the
centipede king he looks to be preparing
a heavy style thrust attack
after that we see a two-handed guard
which then chains into a two-handed
strike
as it's slower perhaps this is also a
strong attack
and that's something worth noting about
the combat it all looks slow and
methodical just like other from software
games
so far it actually looks more similar to
the speed of the soul series
as opposed to the faster pace of
bloodborne or securo but that could also
be due to the weapons we're seeing
showcased here
as it's a from software game a giant
castle is up next
guarded by what looks to be a boss
similar to the cleric beast of
bloodborne
like the cleric beast this enemy jumps
out at the protagonist as he's walking
across a bridge to enter a new area
in this encounter we see rolling
utilized by the protagonist similar to
previous from software games
and while the dodge was used to evade a
strike i have to imagine iframes will
still be in place
in a later fight in the trailer we do
see the player character dodge through a
magical attack
so it seems likely that using the timing
of iframes to avoid damage will be a
part of combat
i do find it interesting that the
two-handed sword guard here was so
effective against what looks like a boss
character
something that's usually a lot weaker in
souls games but was a major mechanic in
securo
only time will tell how effective this
type of guarding will be compared to
dodging
this is pure speculation but perhaps
certain weapons will not only have
offensive attributes but also defensive
attributes
we do see shields later on in the
trailer and this would definitely be an
interesting new gameplay mechanic to
think about another detail we saw was
that both the enemy and protagonists
utilize enhanced magical strikes
and speaking of which we do get to see
multiple weapons utilized in the trailer
this includes a curved sword a bow a
whip and much more
this means that the number of weapons
will likely be more akin to the soul
series rather than the limited number in
bloodborne and sekiro's single weapon
on bandai namco's official alden ring
website the developer reveals that
similar to previous souls games we'll be
able to create a character
and define our playstyle by
experimenting with a wide variety of
weapons
magical abilities and skills found
throughout the world
a cloaked female character gives us some
exposition it's possible this will be
elder ring's version of the maiden and
black slash
emerald herald we get to see more
horseback travel which is a great time
to mention that the world of elder ring
is going to be one that's much larger
than previous from software games
according to bandai namco the world and
dungeons are fully connected
unlike bloodborne and demon's souls that
said it's hard to tell
just yet if the world will wrap into
itself as well as dark souls 1 did
outside of the tree we see a character
resting at a bonfire
it's hard to say what type of gameplay
mechanic this will serve or if it's more
so an homage to dark souls
we see an anthropomorphic character
howling who now has a wolf head
next we see a new gameplay mechanic
where the character uses a cube that
creates what looks to be allies who can
help the character in a fight
bandai namco's website reveals that
multiplayer will be an option in elton
ring and confirms co-op play of up to
four players
that said no word yet that i'm aware of
on pvp
it wouldn't be a medieval from software
game without a dragon
so we get to see a horseback battle with
a four-wing dragon
who seems to harness its inner gwyn
utilizing lightning
i do wonder if certain bosses will be
better to fight horseback and if other
ones are better to fight sans the horse
it also makes me wonder if you can only
use the horse during certain portions of
the game
maybe only outside in the open or even
for a limited duration
afterwards a lycan style boss with the
wolfish face
it's likely there's a relation here to
the other liking creature we saw earlier
in the trailer
next up the valkyrie putting on its arm
that we saw from the very first eldon
ring trailer two years ago
it seems clear now that the valkyrie is
likely an upcoming boss fight and a
demigod
given the similar hair color armor and
skin affliction that looks similar
to greyscale from a song of ice and fire
i'm fairly certain this is the same
character
and it's possible that one of the
cutscenes might have actually been from
the intro to elder ring
something i couldn't help but notice is
that this night she's destroying looks
stylized
just like a faram armor wearing knight
of dark souls 2
just minus the padding which brings me
to my next exciting point
it looks like fashion souls is back and
we've seen multiple types of armor on
our protagonists
although i guess that would be called
fashion ring something we saw in the
first trailer that was ultra interesting
to me
was this creature that looks like it has
multiple arms
given the grey hair and crown i think
that we're finally seeing this demi god
in action in this new trailer
and of course it looks like this will be
an amazingly cool
boss fight kyo montage of what looks to
be various boss battles
i'm not going to comment on all of them
but in particular i love the giant hand
that makes its way to the protagonist
seriously it is just so cool next up is
a castle that reminds me a little bit of
irithyll of the boreal valley from dark
souls 3.
i doubt that's what this is but i can't
shake the feeling that this looks
familiar
in the next action montage and an
exciting feature for magic users
is that we get to see a catalyst in
action so
again this game looks much more similar
to dark souls 1 in terms of weapon
customization and perhaps
builds we also get to see the mechanics
of sneaking behind an enemy in action
which is more reminiscent of securo
which involves sneaking as an important
mechanic
and speaking of hands we get another
hand grabbing what could be the
protagonist before finding clothes
this again is going into speculation
territory but this shot stood out to me
as i can't think of any reason you'd
witness
this except for one of two reasons
either a
this is a cutscene before a boss with
the boss having the giant hand and it's
showcasing what the boss can do
or you know maybe the character being
grabbed by the hand is the boss using
his powers
or b and what i actually think is more
likely perhaps this is closer to the
beginning of the game and has something
to do with how your character is taken
to a realm which kicks off the rest of
the game
it just seems too odd that the person
being grabbed doesn't have any clothes
and has a face that isn't particularly
striking
finally we get a release date and a cool
backdrop but let's break this down a
little further
the backdrop shows the protagonist
sticking their sword into the ground in
a heap
what this actually reminds me a bit of
is a dropped element from dark souls 3
where if i'm remembering correctly the
player could create their own bonfires
so it'd be interesting this idea was
retooled and now being used for elder
ring
and some of the best news is how
available the game is going to be
this game won't be an exclusive and
those of you who haven't been able to
secure next gen console don't have to
fret
the game will be available on ps5 ps4
xbox series x xbox one and pc
and we don't even have to wait that much
longer the game has a release date of
january 21
2022 one more thing to jump into before
i wrap up
and that's the lore a lot of lore
actually dropped on bandai namco's
official eldon ring website
rather than the trailer itself which is
a little more cryptic per from software
style
so what do we know in the lands between
ruled by queen marika the eternal
the elder ring the source of the urgery
has been shattered
marika's offspring demi godzal claimed
the shards of the elder ring known as
the great runes
and the mad taint of their newfound
strength triggered a war
the shattering a war that meant
abandonment by the greater will
and now the guidance of grace will be
brought to the tarnished who were
spurned by the grace of gold and exiled
from the lands between
ye dead who yet live your grace long
lost
follow the path to the lands between
beyond the foggy sea
to stand before the elden ring and
become the elden lord okay given all of
this
here's what i think it seems clear you
play as one of the tarnished
i find it likely that the hand we saw in
the trailer is taking you
the tarnished to the start of your
journey to the lands between
some of the most major enemies we see
such as the boss character with multiple
hands and the valkyrie-like character
are very likely morika's offspring and
the demigods who you'll have to face off
against
we see that from the character with many
hands who says
[Music]
[Music]
a lot of this reminds me deeply of dark
souls one story
you play as a tarnished who's dead but
also living similar to the undead of
dark souls
you have an unending curse which would
seem to make you tarnished
the demigods you fight are similar in a
way to gwyn
nido and the witch of izalith however it
seems you're now fighting these demigods
at the height of their power
and as this is a from software game i
have a feeling there's much more to it
when you're told to become the elden
lord
and finding the elder ring might not be
all as cracked up to be
i am so so excited that the next from
software game is almost here
is there anything i missed and what has
you the most excited
january cannot come soon enough and i
can't wait to chat more alden ring with
all of you
[Music]
you